it's like my world is
washed out and i see fewer shades of
color than most people do
so normal people see a million colors i
may see as many as a hundred million
my name is wendy i'm a producer at cnn
and i am colorblind
my name is maureen seberg i'm a
tetrachromat and i'm an author
tetrachromacy
is the presence of a fourth cone class
in your retina
if i keep naming my invisible colors
maybe i'll have my own crayola box one
day
when i was in kindergarten my teacher
called my parents because i was coloring
the leaves of my trees and the trunks of
my trees the same color because i
couldn't really see the difference
between green and brown the only time it
was ever overwhelming
is a paint contractor came to my house
and brought no fewer than 32 samples
before i was satisfied that it was a
true beige
when i pick out clothes
that's hard
i have been known to buy the outfit that
the mannequin is wearing because i know
that that goes together you don't want
to go clothing shopping with me because
the sales people tell me but it matches
and i can only look at them
sympathetically and keep looking
i never think like oh if i weren't
colorblind it would be so much easier to
get dressed in the morning it's just
it's kind of part of me i guess i'm a
unicorn or something
you